hey this is preshtalwalker
start with the unit square
we'll create a new rectangle as follows
we'll attach a rectangle of area one to
the side
we will then attach a rectangle of area
1 to the top
the border of the shape is a new
rectangle
we'll label our starting rectangle r sub
1.
the new rectangle we created will be
labeled r sub 2.
we'll now repeat this process starting
with r sub 2.
we'll create a new rectangle by
attaching a rectangle of area 1 to its
side then we'll attach a rectangle area
1 to its top
this creates the next rectangle r sub 3.
we can repeat this process indefinitely
starting with rectangle r sub n minus 1
we can create a new rectangle by
attaching a rectangle of area 1 to its
side and then a rectangle of area 1 to
its top
this creates the next rectangle r sub n
each of these rectangles has a length
and a width
the question is
what is the ratio of the length to the
width of r sub n as n goes to infinity
in other words what is the limit as n
goes to infinity of l sub n divided by w
sub n
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
we'll get started with our first
rectangle which is a unit square
the length and the width of this
rectangle are 1.
what happens in the next step of the
process
we first attach a rectangle of area 1 to
the side
we know the width of the original
rectangle is one
therefore the length of this new
rectangle has to be one divided by one
in order that the area be equal to one
we now attach a rectangle with area one
to the top
this new rectangle
has a length
that's equal to two
in order for the area to be equal to one
the length the width of this rectangle
has to be equal to one divided by two
we therefore have a rectangle r sub two
where its length is equal to two and its
width is equal to three
halves the ratio in this rectangle is
equal to two divided by three halves
which is equal to two over one times two
over three
what happens for the general case we
start with the rectangle r sub n
this rectangle has a width and a length
we first attach a rectangle of area one
to the side
the width of this rectangle is equal to
w sub n
so its length has to be equal to 1
divided by w sub n so that its area is
equal to 1.
this gives us a formula that the next
length of the next rectangle is equal to
the previous length plus one divided by
the previous width
we then attach a rectangle of area one
to the top
now the length of this rectangle is
equal to l sub n plus 1 over w sub n
in order that the area be equal to 1
we need the width of this rectangle to
be the reciprocal of this quantity
now we can simplify this fraction by
multiplying by w sub n
we now have a term l sub n w sub n
this is equal to the length times the
width of rectangle n
in other words this term is the area of
rectangle r sub n
the first rectangle was a unit square
which had area one
the next rectangle had two rectangles of
area one added to it so its total area
would have been three
and in general
the area of r sub n will be equal to 2
times n minus 1 because each time we
take a step in this process we're adding
two units to the area
so we can substitute in 2n minus 1 for
this term l sub n times w sub n
we end up with the formula
w sub n divided by two n
so this is the amount that the width
grows in the new rectangle which we need
to add to the previous width
we now have formulas for the length and
the width of the new rectangle in terms
of the length and the width of the
previous rectangle
we now want to compute the ratio of the
length to the width
we'll use our recursive formulas
we can simplify this fraction by
multiplying the numerator and
denominator by 2n times w sub n
we again have the term
l sub n times w sub n which is the area
of rectangle r sub n
we can simplify this formula
and now we have one more term we need to
simplify this is the width of rectangle
n squared
we can rewrite this in terms of things
we already know and care about
the width of rectangle n squared is
equal to the area of rectangle n divided
by the ratio of the length to the width
of rectangle n
if we substitute this in
we have the area being equal to two n
minus one
so putting it back into our main
fraction
we end up getting the new ratio of is
equal to the ratio of the length to the
width of rectangle n
times two fractions
we have two n divided by two n minus one
and then we have two n divided by two n
plus one
so let's compute a few of the terms
using this recursive formula
we start out with the unit square which
has a ratio of its length to its width
of one
the next rectangle will have a ratio
that's two over one times two over three
times the previous ratio of one
we can omit this term of one because it
won't affect the ultimate product
the next rectangle will have a ratio
that's four over three times four over
five times the previous ratio
the next rectangle will have a ratio
that's 6 over 5 times 6 over 7 times the
previous ratio
this pattern will continue indefinitely
the ratio of the length to the width as
n goes to infinity will therefore be an
infinite product
we have the product of the fractions 2k
over 2k minus 1 times 2k over 2k plus 1
where k runs from 1 to infinity
what does this evaluate to
this is a famous formula and it exactly
equals pi divided by 2 which is
approximately 1.571
this is known as the wallace product
formula for pi and it was first
described in 1655.
i know some of you will be curious about
how to prove this formula and you can
check out a video i made on this i
provided a link in the video description
and it's an interesting example of how
you can use calculus to prove this
formula
so we end up with a very surprising
answer we started out with the square
and we kept adding rectangles to its
side and to the top
we ended up creating a rectangle whose
ratio of its length to its width is
actually related to pi and i find that
quite interesting that you can start out
with just rectangles and you end up with
pi
did you figure this out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description